all right let's get into audience
questions for the week a bunch of
questions about the recent 60 minutes
ufo uap
uh piece that was done the general gist
of the questions is david what's your
view
about the truth of the recent ufo uap
story now uap is a relatively at least
in the public space new term
for uh unidentified foreign objects
called unidentified aerial phenomena
sorry unidentified flying objects
the new uap is unidentified aerial
phenomena
my view on this is i don't think
anybody is lying about what they believe
they saw
when you see pilots interviewed and
saying we saw this moving in that way at
this speed and we don't know this that
the other thing
i believe everybody so far is being
honest in their perceptions
i believe we only have part of the story
and i have no evidence at this point
that we are dealing with
aliens from another planet and this is
the most important thing to remember
just because we say
there's a ufo that's an unidentified
flying object it's an object that's
flying and we don't know exactly what it
is
uh doesn't mean that it's aliens and
similarly an unidentified aerial
phenomena
uh has the sort of same analysis now
i've said before
uh if there is an intelligent
interstellar
um traveling uh species
or human a society of some kind that
comes to the united states
if we default to treating it as a threat
the way for example marco rubio said
these uaps ufos
are def these are threats uh well they
may be a threat if they are
you know if it's spy technology from an
adversary
then we're talking about national
security but if we did
get a visit from aliens and we treat it
as a threat when they are actually not a
threat if they come in peace
so to speak um then we could potentially
uh destroy what would be a historic
species-changing encounter
and the reality is that at this point
since we lack the technology to do
what we imagine maybe someday would
happen which is some
uh alien race from somewhere else in the
universe comes to the united states
if they came with nefarious goals it's
abundantly clear that at least at this
time
we would be able to do nothing to
prevent them from either killing all of
us or enslaving all of us or whatever so
for me
the national security analysis makes
more sense
if we're conceding that the most likely
explanation
is that this is either something from a
foreign power
in which case by the way if we really
don't understand what it is
then they are way further ahead than us
in many ways
and we should be extremely worried uh or
it's also possible that these
are unidentified or unknown to the
pilots and people that were interviewed
for the 60 minutes piece
but that it actually is classified at a
level above their
uh pay grade or level of access and the
people who know what these things are
did not participate uh because maybe 60
minutes doesn't even know who they are
so i i think my main point here is
for me the most serious approach to this
ufo uap
thing is first of all there is no
evidence that this is aliens from
somewhere other than earth there's just
no evidence of that and it's fascinating
to think of and i
understand the equations about the
probability of intelligent life other
than just
on earth earth and i recognize that if
we were ever to make that first contact
it would truly be an incredible thing
i'm not saying it's not possible i'm
just saying there's no evidence that
this is
that then it gets to the question of
assuming that it is indeed
man-made technology then
what is the source of it is it something
american that is so classified that even
the people interviewed don't know what
it is
uh or is it something foreign and then
you get the people who say well the
physics of it doesn't make sense
there were uh dissents in altitude
that would have killed any human body
that was in there
uh okay maybe there wasn't a human body
in there we also know
that the way a lot of these things are
filmed and perspective
and lenses can make something seem
different than what it might look like
to the naked eye
the where i come back to is
sort of an occam's razor type question
which is which of these explanations
require the fewest assumptions and the
ones that require the fewest assumptions
are
the visual perception that the pilots
claim is not entirely accurate that
would be a very straightforward way to
explain away a lot of this or
this is stuff that is known it's not
unidentified it was unidentified to the
pilots
and maybe to air traffic control but
it's
technology that higher up we are aware
of
or it was human-made technology from
some other place like the
from some other country the one that is
the furthest
and requires the most assumptions of
course would be the alien one which is
there is an alien species that is
advanced enough to travel
to earth from really far in the universe
because we've been observing the
universe that's more immediately around
us for a very long time
and to do it without any other signature
be it radio waves or whatever
else and right so the number of
assumptions start to go up
significantly so that's not where i am
on this now just one other thought on
this
one thing i read was the information
that was released
was fake information released by the us
government
to trick other countries what's the idea
here this is quite cynical
and if you go down this rabbit hole
the pilots interviewed on 60 minutes
could be in on it or not they might not
even be in on it the idea would be
let's make some video and have pilots
tell stories
or otherwise convince pilots of the
reality of this
so that 60 minutes we'll do a piece
we'll have some big reveal about these
uap ufos and
this will be seen by our adversaries and
it will completely misdirect them
so that they will start sinking r d
money into what they think they need to
do to develop
these things and it's just it's either
digital
it's not even real it's just been made
uh on a computer
um and it's a way to get adversaries to
spend money unfortunately
that's not totally implausible compared
to the alien theory uh
the the deliberate misdirection campaign
by
by the us government strikes me as more
plausible
send me your thoughts that's kind of
where my head is on this at this point
in time
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation
because they're either dry or boring or
don't taste that good or
they don't satisfy your cravings but our
sponsor monk pack
is completely different because monk
pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture and yet
they have only 140 calories
one gram of sugar and only two to three
net carbs perfect
for the low sugar or keto diet they come
in
fantastic flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
blueberry almond vanilla and the new
flavor
peanut butter i've been a fan for a long
time i always have them in my pantry
it is a perfect snack and if you don't
love them as much as i do
you get all your money back they also
now have a subscription feature which i
love it'll save you 10 percent on every
order
and it ships automatically you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video